JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you've
started learning
about quadratic approximation.
So today we're just going
to do a quick example of it.
So I have a question
written here on the board:
What is the quadratic
approximation of the function
f of x equals e to the x plus x
squared-- so here x and plus x
squared is the exponent,
so it's e to the quantity
x plus x squared--
near x equals 0.
So why don't you take a minute
or two, pause the video,
work this out on your
own and then come back
and we can do it together.
All right.
Welcome back.
So there are two different
ways we can do this problem.
Let's first just do it the
totally straightforward way,
which is that you
have this formula
for quadratic
approximations in terms
of the derivatives
of your function.
And so, so we can just
apply that formula.
So here, so the formula is that
the quadratic approximation
of the function f-- so
here, near the point 0--
is equal to f of 0 plus f prime
of 0 x plus f double prime of 0
over 2 times x squared.
All right.
So in order to use
this formula we just
need to know what the
derivatives of our function
are and their values at 0.
So first we can do the
first derivative of f.
So for that it's just a
straightforward application
of the chain rule.
Our outer function is e to
the x and our inner function
is x plus x squared.
So the derivative then, applying
the chain rule, is e to the x
plus x squared times 1 plus 2x,
which I can also write as e--
well, yeah, let me
just reorder it-- 2x
plus 1 times e to
the x plus x squared.
OK.
So that's the first derivative.
And for the second derivative I
can apply just the product rule
here.
Right?
So I've got this-- you
know, the second derivative
is the derivative of
the first derivative,
so here I have a product.
So f double prime of
x is equal to-- well,
so we take the derivative of
the first one, which is just 2,
times the second plus the
derivative of the second one.
Well, the second one is e
to the x plus x squared.
It's actually f of x, so we
already computed it once.
So the derivative of the
second is 2x plus 1 e to the x
plus x squared times the first.
So times another 2x plus 1.
OK, and if I multiply these
two together and combine
all my terms, this is 4x
squared plus 4x plus 3 times
e to the x plus x squared.
So these are the first
and second derivatives,
and what I need to plug
them into my formula
is I need their values at 0.
So I need the
function value at 0.
So f of 0, well that's e
to the 0 plus 0 squared.
So it's e to the 0,
so that's just 1.
f prime at 0, let's see, I go
over to my formula for f prime
and I plug in x equals 0,
so I have 2 times 0 plus 1,
so that's 1, times e to the 0.
So that's 1 times
1, that's also 1.
And for f double time
at 0, I go to my formula
for f double prime
and I put in 0.
And so this is 0 and that's 0.
So I have a 3 times
1 so that's 3.
And now I just take
these three values
and I plug them right
into my formula.
So the quadratic
approximation is
Q of f equals 1 plus x
plus 3 x squared over 2.
All right.
Great.
So that was one way
to do this problem.
Another way to do this
problem is the following.
And in this case, I'm not
sure which way is simpler,
but in some cases one way is
clearly easier than the other.
So if we illustrate
both then you'll
have twice as many
tools to work with.
So the other way is to notice--
so the exponential function is
nice.
When you have-- you know,
one of your exponential rules
is that the exponential
of a sum is the product
of the exponentials.
So we can rewrite f of x
equals e to the x times
e to the x squared.
Now this may seem a
little bit silly to you,
but if you watched
Christine's recitation
video you saw that to find
the quadratic approximation
to a product, it's
enough to find
the quadratic
approximations to each piece
separately, multiply
together, and then take
that quadratic approximation.
So in this case the
quadratic approximations
are things you
might already know.
So in particular, we
saw in recit-- sorry,
in lecture that the quadratic
approximation of e to the x
is 1 plus x plus
x squared over 2.
And I'm going to tell you--
if you haven't seen it
in recitation, there are
a bunch of different ways
you could work it
out for yourself--
but the quadratic approximation
for e to the x squared
is equal to 1 plus x squared.
All right, so if you
don't believe me,
by all means work that out
for yourself to check it.
So in this case,
so that means that
the quadratic approximation
of f is equal to-- by the rule
Christine showed you--
it's the, so it's
equal to the quadratic
approximation
of the product of the
quadratic approximations.
So that's 1 plus
x plus x squared
over 2 times 1 plus x squared.
Now if you multiply these
two out, that's not hard.
There are six terms.
So this is the quadratic
approximation of 1
plus x plus x squared over 2.
So multiply 1 through
here and now x squared.
So that's plus x
squared plus x cubed
plus-- OK, some fourth degree
term-- x to the fourth over 2.
And now the quadratic
approximation to this we
get just by dropping the
cubic and quartic terms.
So-- and OK, and we can
add these two square terms
together.
So this is equal to 1 plus
x plus 3 x squared over 2.
All right.
And luckily, doing the same
problem two different ways we
get the same answer, which
is what should happen.
So that's that.